hey guys it's justine and i'm jenna
welcome to episode 8 of same brain
podcast
featuring a special guest this is our
first guest
i'm so excited jenna today we have phil
spencer on our podcast
today xbox had the xbox games showcase
with so
many incredible announcements and of
course the highly anticipated halo
infinite yeah we got actual gameplay
today which was really exciting and this
is a game that is very special to me and
jenna because we used to play this game
together
all the time i mean even xbox in general
i feel like is so special like we grew
up gaming
but we really got into console gaming
with xbox for sure and i mean
halo was one of the first games that i'd
ever played on xbox so to kind of just
watch this
especially watch it with jenna it was
just that nostalgia feel
i think is something that a lot of
people experienced while watching this
and what's even better is we got a
chance to sit down
with phil spencer and talk about the
xbox games showcase
phil thank you so much for joining us on
our podcast this is our first guest ever
how are we going to top this
i'm honored to be the first guest when
they told me that i was like no way but
you guys just started in june right
yes yes congrats on that it's awesome
thank you thank you we're on episode
8 i believe and this is a very exciting
a special edition obviously and
congratulations on the showcase today it
was incredible
it was really fun so for you guys i mean
you're so used to doing these events
live i mean this whole thing has been
such
a completely different experience so
how's it been for you guys trying to put
these things on
and sort of appeal to everything that
gamers are hoping to see yeah
both of you are so familiar with
production and just all the work that
goes into this and
you know we did this in a production
studio here in seattle and everybody's
social distancing everybody has their
masks on
people are obviously working on getting
the games done and the trailers done so
it's just really proud
of the way the team showed up to really
uh
show the best that they had the show
came off i'll admit
i miss the energy and the fans kind of
on stage at e3 is always one of those
special moments
but it was uh really cool just to see
how the the team came together to pull
off something in a
unique way it looked really great i
think that's completely changing the way
that everyone is sort of operating
especially with gaming i mean even
during all of this
i feel like gaming has brought us all so
much closer together
for sure yeah yeah we definitely see
that i mean i was i'm trying to remember
the stats it was like from the beginning
of stay at home we've had like over
270 million new friend connections made
on xbox live and something
which is just i mean it's not so much
about xbox live it's just the power of
gaming
uh that allows people when they can't
physically be with their friends or hang
out with people that they can do that
through the power of
play and i just think that's such an
awesome thing about our industry for
sure yeah and we're so used to like
traveling so much you know for fun
and work and we've been gaming our
entire lives and just being busy you
know being
adults and working we kind of stepped
away just because there wasn't enough
time
so now being home we kind of
rediscovered our love for gaming
and we're like we missed this so much
and we've actually probably talked to
our friends
more so now being at home because we'll
like hop on and play games every night
so it's definitely really
interesting and i've been having a great
time just staying home playing video
games
and even for us though halo like us
watching this showcase
it brought back so many fun times
because before jenna moved to los
angeles
she was living with me and we used to
play split screen multiplayer and co-op
and everything together just sitting in
our living room so just watching this
i think for both of us it brought back
that nostalgia so
i know that's something that's very
important to you guys as well yeah you
know bonnie ross and the team at 343
wanted really to bring back that kind of
classic halo feel and as i've watched
uh the gameplay come together there was
just something about when
chief walks out the back of that pelican
that
just i felt at home every time i've seen
it obviously i've played
the game a number of times but you're
right i mean gaming creates those
memories those memories
of who we played with where were we and
who are we with at the time we finished
this game
and halo plays such a special role not
only for us and xbox but i think for so
many gamers it was just awesome to be
able to
open the show with halo and all of the
love that we've been feeling today of
people
yes like the sound the look the
characters the
the ring like it was it's just really
nice like a coming home moment for
millions of xbox fans i mean halo was
definitely my first introduction
to xbox a long time ago i'm a little bit
older than jenna
so i feel like we kind of have that
little bit of a disconnect but again
gaming did bring us together when i was
living in california she was back in
pennsylvania so i just i love the way
that gaming has just made that
connection for sure so
i think there was also one of the things
on twitter that i saw a bunch of people
were so surprised to see the
announcement of fable
yes so that small little teaser i mean
everyone was really excited and i think
what's amazing is all the games that you
guys showed here today were all xbox
game pass games
yeah i definitely think game pass was
the the star of the show
um and you know that's a big change like
it's it's normally when we think about a
console launch it's just
focus on the individual game titles and
we want to do that clearly we want to do
that
but at the same time we know especially
right now value in gaming is important
obviously there's a global pandemic
going on around us and the
economy is where it is and we want to
give families and people
choice about how they build their
libraries and the fact that we could do
a full show and every game in the show
was in game pass i thought was just such
a such a great statement for the service
um and how it's grown and be able to
close the show as you say with fable
a great studio with playground i think
it's kind of been the worst kept secret
in video games
i'm still working on fable some of those
leaks might even bend from me
but it was it's really nice to now have
it out there so we can talk about it
um and just kind of have more of a
direct discussion with the fans
honestly i've been surprised by the
reaction to fable i worked on the first
fable
and as you when you work on a game
sometimes you you have a different
connection with it
um but today just the the fanfare around
the fable announced it's been fantastic
to see and i thank everyone for that
i think we're all so focused on halo
halo halo but there was
nothing that we thought that you could
do that could top sort of that
announcement so i think you guys did a
really great job with that we were even
talking earlier
like man i remember it was 2019 e3 even
when like the halo was teased in the
series x and like how excited we were
we're like well here we are you know
it's happening soon holiday
2020. it's gonna be here before we know
it our cfo in the microsoft earnings
yesterday and the microsoft earnings got
asked when were
console launches which you know we've
come a long way inside of microsoft when
they're asking our
our corporate executives about console
launches but yeah this
it's uh it's 2020 it's a launch here not
just us our friends at sony obviously
launching console as well
uh so it's you know a lot of excitement
in gaming right now
nintendo is doing incredibly well i
think you guys are playing a lot of
animal crossing and stuff
yes yeah i mean i'm over like 650 hours
right now
so and it's honestly unhealthy it really
is unhealthy but i think
i would have never had time to do that
previously so we're in such this unique
position to sort of refocus and and do a
lot of things that we might not have had
time to do before
so i mean for you like are there any
games that you feel like you have more
time to play now or like
able to do other sort of activities that
you couldn't before yeah i'm playing a
lot
um which is always part of my life you
know
and i think about that experience i mean
you're in the perfect example you're
you're not at home right now you're in
your secret location doing your cool
stuff
you know when we think about xcloud um
and allowing people to bring
their game past games with them and
continue to play them wherever they are
as they move around i think it's just a
great thing about today's big franchises
whether it's a fortnight or a minecraft
where you can kind of always stay
connected with them wherever you go and
obviously the portability of a switch
gives you that
with animal crossing so we were thinking
about xcloud coming into game pass
and then that means now i can take my
xbox library with me
sure when i'm at home i'll probably pay
on my big screen because that's what i
like
uh but when i'm not at home and i want
to have those options i just think it
it makes gaming you more ubiquitous and
kind of constant part
um of my life which is something i love
yeah cause i feel like before we used to
be tied to our tv
and we used to travel home like for the
holidays both of us would bring an xbox
be like fully prepared so now we can
play it all on mobile and i also love
that minecraft dungeons was on nintendo
switch that was really cool
so fun because i could easily take that
kind of stuff with me so i'm definitely
looking forward to
the future of more sort of
collaborations like that if that's
anything that is in the future
i'm here for it and i know a lot of
people would be too i'm just glad we
don't have to carry our xbox home with
us now as our carry-on because yeah
i mean you know there weren't many
direct flights from la to pittsburgh
and that thing got a little heavy so now
all that you know xcloud is the thing
i'm personally very excited i've been
running the beta
playing halo and it's been really great
oh that's awesome it's so great well
maybe we just buy mom and dad and xbox
we do have so we we have
we have upgraded um we have eventually
they have one there my grandmother
actually had it was like the gears one
of the first gears xboxes
yeah so when i upgraded i gave her my
gear's xbox so she still has it we came
over one day and she was just like
playing
i was like remember are you playing
she's playing right now she's playing
call of duty and gears of war i'm like
she's like i want to try it out i'm like
this is incredible yeah gaming does
cross
such a huge expansive audience and i
just i think it's incredible and it's
really has changed the world
like for sure you guys are doing what
everyone is doing yeah and i think as
you said people staying connected
across different devices every time i
sit down i have my characters my friends
are there i can just keep playing
i mean that's what gaming is about to me
gaming is a unique art form on our
planet that
i do with my community i do with my
friends usually when i'm watching tv or
listen to music it's kind of a solo
thing but when i play video games i just
love playing co-op with friends and the
fact that gaming has just become more
connected
um overall and especially right now when
you know we feel so disconnected or
we're on the road
and this i think is fantastic and seeing
the industry embrace that and realize
that all of us working together
to allow gamers to stay connected is
actually a great way for gaming all up
to continue to grow
and that just is gaining more and more
momentum across the industry which is a
lot of fun
and we recently started streaming
because we're like okay we're home like
we're not making the usual content like
how do we you know interact with our
audience we're like well let's just
start streaming our video games
and i mean i've been doing youtube for
10 years you've been doing it for it's
way too long way too long
and i on i finally feel like this
streaming and like the video games have
brought us like so much closer
to our audience so it's been it's just
been this weird thing we're like wow
what have we been doing wrong for 10
years but like gaming has just like
brought us all together so it's been
really cool
yeah the content creator i mean it's you
know as important as players as creators
of the games themselves you just have so
many
kind of different people that play a
role in someone's game experience like
we see it
people go online now to see what their
kind of trusted people they follow what
do they think of the games getting their
opinions
uh i mean it's it it's just really bring
it makes gaming more accessible when i
can go online i can search for a game
and watch a streamer play it or watch
somebody on youtube
kind of give them their impression and i
think that that kind of ability for me
to find my next favorite game
something that's outside of the three or
four games that i always go to
uh the diversity of games that we see in
the market right now is i just think a
a real strength for our industry we need
more people to find more games to play
that's just
for sure also i want to talk about
accessibility because you hit on that a
little bit so as far as
making games more accessible i think is
something that you guys have been
very ahead of the curve on i know we
went up to microsoft um it's a few years
back to get a chance to see like the
accessibility
and talk about like the um the
controller that you guys the adaptive
controller
so like things like that like that's
incredible so is that all going to be
supported as well
on series x are you doing anything to
kind of push that initiative yeah
the xbox adaptive controller will be
there it'll be supported i think it's
as you said we want more people to play
more voices are heard more voices to be
for that to be safe i mean it's it's
something i know you've talked about in
terms of when you're online i want to
make sure that the community i'm playing
with and interacting with the people i
choose
and that i'm able to kind of manage
those communities and bringing more
people in with different perspectives
accessibility is a critical part of that
and again i'll say as the industry we've
done our part with the work that we've
done
but you know the last of us two just
came out and congrats to neil and the
team did a great job with the
accessibility in that game
and i see us all kind of learning and
building on the work
of each other which is absolutely the
way it should be like accessibility
should not be a platform
competitive thing uh it should be
something that we all embrace in order
to allow more people to play
and even after the show today we did a
bunch of work on localization
sign language in our show to make sure
more people can see it the feedback we
get from cyanide impaired people about
how we can continue to work
to make gaming more accessible it's just
i think as you said a really important
thing for us as an industry to focus on
and i'm really pleased with the progress
that we continue to it's amazing i mean
i saw firsthand just you know a bunch of
youtube videos people talking about how
this really did change their lives
because before they were never able to
play
and just seeing people play video games
for the first time was just it was so
heartwarming
so for sure for all of them thank you
guys
so that's it's really impressive it's
good to talk about i'm glad you bring it
up because i think that's what it needs
right it needs to be
constantly in our conversation of how do
we have representation
in our games representation in our
community uh
yeah it's almost like a meme now i say
it so often there are over two billion
people on the planet that play video
games which is just amazing
um to think about and getting those
creator voices
whether those are creators of people as
making videos about
video games or making the games
themselves it just really strengthens
what gaming can do on the planet as more
people are able to engage so i
appreciate you talking about it
and continue to do that please i think
it's uh it just makes it a focus
you don't have too much time but is
there anything else that you want to
tell us about
halo that we think the audience might
enjoy because i know we're super excited
about it
i mean i love the campaigns but
obviously we're huge multiplayer fans so
we're just going to wait very patiently
you know whenever that announcement
comes you know we'll be ready
waiting but as far as like the campaign
goes i mean what are you most looking
forward to
yeah the multiplayer in halo infinite i
think is going to be special when we
talk about it
um you know there's such it's such a big
game when you think about all the work
that goes into the single player
campaign
to the community features to multiplayer
but we know for so many people
you know halo ce started with us lugging
our xboxes around
plugging them in together and playing
console multiplayer for many of us the
first
time so i'm excited about what we'll get
to see uh
and what we'll get to show i think the
team's building on what they did with
halo 5 and the multiplayer in halo 5 was
received very well
so it's cool to kind of see the team
continue to iterate on things that the
community loves
the esport players have been heavily
involved
in what we're doing because we know
that's a strong part of the community
the professional players
and there's some kind of technical uh
challenges the team has set for
themselves on multiplayer that i'm
really encouraged to be able to talk
about
uh when we get there so soon we will be
able to talk about halo multiplayer soon
uh but bonnie and the team are doing a
really good job with halo and it's nice
it's been a long time 19 years since we
had a halo with the launch of it oh my
gosh that's really crazy oh my gosh
2001 original xbox and halo ce so this
is like a seminal moment for us these
are chocolate and peanut butter coming
together like it's going to be a special
time when we're able to
to launch halo in the next console i
mean i feel like you're in such a unique
position because you've been with
microsoft for so long so i mean
how exciting is this though for you to
sort of see all of this just happen
in a lifetime like it's really
incredible yeah you know i went back
so as my i was there at the original
xbox launch of 360 xbox one
um and there are a lot of team members
on xbox that haven't been around as long
as i have
and i really push the team to to embrace
it and kind of it's one of those
career accomplishments and frankly life
accomplishments
that it's easy to kind of just fly right
through but you've been around console
launches before there's something
special about that i went back and i
watched some of the video from zero hour
if you remember that on 360 when we went
out in the desert and brought a bunch of
people in and
you know it's just such a special time
for the community and the team so i get
excited i was nervous today
which i thought was funny because the
whole thing was recorded so like i
couldn't really mess anything up
but uh it's nice to get the kind of
energy flowing
and just to feel the fan energy the
viewership today was amazing
um and this is going to be great this is
kind of what it's all about
it's just celebrating with fans love of
video games launching a new xbox
launching some great games and getting
talked to people who really care about
it so i appreciate the opportunity
i mean you guys are saving our 2020. you
really are like video games are keeping
us all
sane so yeah thank you to you guys but
yeah
it's not a very high bar oh
yeah we're ready for 2021 oh my gosh
we'll have lots more games well i mean
that's also going to be exciting because
the future of games so 2021 i can only
imagine what we're going to be expecting
maybe we'll have
20 frames per second ori by the way or
is oh my gosh i
personally am just going to be so
excited because it's just going to look
so
nice i mean it already is such a
beautiful game but 120 frames oh my gosh
yeah it's a big focus we're seeing a lot
of games right like dirt was another one
that's talking about 120 we'll have more
to
to talk about in terms of high frame
rate like that feel of games is
something that
we're definitely going to feel at launch
and as you talk about in the future i
think
that's an area that i see developers
really getting
getting into is how do i make sure that
the games
feel as great as they look uh huge
opportunity and and really be fun to be
able to talk more about that as as
yeah i mean especially because a lot of
these games you are going to be able to
play backwards compatible
and on other things so i think it's
going to be such a challenge to make
sure it plays
incredible on the new gen consoles but
also you know previous as well for sure
yeah the back compat team for us is
they're like our
our ninjas in the back room that just do
amazing work and
without spoiling too much seeing some of
the frame rate
work they've been able to do on our back
compact games to
up the frame rate on existing games is
it's just
it it's not normal in console that when
i buy a new console my old games
actually play and they play
better uh but as we get to continue to
tell more of that i think people really
be impressed with the work that that
team
has done i'm really proud of them uh and
focusing i think on the
investment gamers have made in xbox and
making sure that continues
whether it's the controllers that you
already own whether it's the games that
you already own
uh respecting a gamer's relationship
with our product to me is just
critically important and something
that's just become a pillar for the team
which is
uh and i'm encouraged to be able to talk
more about it should be august i think
august we'll have more
oh my birthday month a nice treat there
we go amazing
thank you well thank you so much for
being our first guest on before we let
you go is there anything else that you
would have liked to have added to the
showcase that you didn't get a chance to
say
since it was already pre-recorded you
know as you said i've been in the
industry for a long time
and i uh i visit studios
and i thought it was really cool to see
the way
like dragon's quest showed up as a game
coming to xbox
the support from japanese publishers
square bringing new ip
into our show obviously tetris effect
was there
pso is coming uh to xbox
again with their new version and it's
just an area of focus for us to make
sure all
creators globally feel like xbox is a
great platform for them
and that they can deliver their games to
a large global audience it's an area
that our team in japan has really been
working hard on
and to be able to open the pre-show with
dragon's quest and then
see continue to see support from great
japanese publishers i think was
something that really popped for me in
the show and it was nice to see a lot of
fans of japanese publishers react to
that
so that was something that i just wanted
to call out because it's uh it means
that's amazing very cool thank you so
much thank you this was incredible
and uh we'll have to game sometime soon
maybe when the new destiny expansion
comes out
[Music]
next to each other and we would just
down bags of doritos
it was it was not a lifestyle that i
should you know continue
24 7 to admit i'm i'm with you on that i
think i'm at
what am i at 10 55 right now my light
level my titan is doing well
and uh it was it was a kind of a
personal project to get destiny into
game pass
getting them to support some stuff so it
was really cool to see sarah get to
announce that
uh in the show and uh thanks to my
friends at
bungie for uh supporting and coming in
the game it's amazing it'll be a lot of
fun to bring more players
yes amazing we'll do some raids soon oh
yeah
well that's it well thank you so much
thank you so much congratulations on
everything yeah thank you
good luck on the secret location and all
that you're doing it's going to be
pretty cool just a lot of sweating too
it's so hot that's ridiculous awesome
well that's great thank you thank you
so there was so much announced today we
couldn't cover everything with phil but
man i'm just
i'm really excited for the future of
gaming we forgot to talk about forza
that's like one of our also favorite
games we went to london last year for
the launch oh my gosh they wouldn't let
me drive the mclaren
well i don't know why i'm not sure why
they wouldn't let me well the good news
is you can play in the game
safely like i'm happy but i'm also sad
because at e3 it's always that really
fun time of the year where we get to
actually go and play the games
and see all of our friends but i think
what xbox and a lot of companies have
been doing is
they're doing a really great job at
these events and trying to make it feel
like
we're together when we're really not for
sure i mean even like i was just on
twitter like seeing what all my friends
were saying like seeing everyone
interact that way like online
you know it doesn't have the same feel
but it still does have the community
feel of just bringing people together
what game are you most excited about so
the grounded trailer
was so funny if you're waiting for the
most anticipated game you should wait
for cyberpunk but in the meantime
yes it was just it was so funny like
that's like my type of humor so that
looked good
state of decay 3 looked so good it
looked scary
well i got a little skipping that when
that when the deer was like zombie deer
ori would have 120 frames per second ori
ori is already such a beautiful game it
really is beautiful man just the future
we're gonna have 60 frames a second halo
very excited though for the multiplayer
of halo i mean i've played the campaigns
but
for me like multiplayer is where i shine
i just
love playing multiplayer because i get
to play with my friends i mean obviously
you can do co-op campaigns and stuff
like that which i don't think they even
mentioned
any co-op campaign stuff i did think so
i don't think so but i am excited
because the campaign is gonna have like
this new
open world it's gonna be bigger there's
gonna be more like side quests i think
so like i love a good side quest 3d maps
oh
those looked really cool we got a little
uh example of what that kind of looks
like some new weapons some new abilities
the grappling book
hello another grappling hole
i mean i just love i don't know i just
love playing games and i'm just really
excited that you know
this is going to be here before we know
it i know we were joking about
gaming saving 2020 but honestly i don't
know what i would have done without
video games during this time i mean i
probably could have done more work but
i didn't want to gaming is like our
escape it's incredible we got to talk to
our friends play with our friends it
just made
life feel normal and i think the main
key about
this xbox game showcase is all these
games are on xbox game pass and i think
having a subscription to games like this
is huge because you're paying one
monthly fee and you can play
a ton of different games and they're
constantly always adding more games too
so you don't have to pay 60
for just one game you can be paying a
monthly subscription and play all kinds
of games
there has probably been every single
person where they're like man i would
really like to play that game but do i
really want to
spend 60 dollars i've done that for sure
so now like having the game
pass if there's a game if i want to try
it out i can actually discover for the
first time maybe i've been missing out
on something just because i didn't want
to pay the 60
so game pass i love what they're doing
with that i think it's incredible i
think it's
genius and it's just really opening up a
whole
new avenue of games yeah even phil was
talking about
how great it is to be able to take games
with you and also playing in the x cloud
so you know before we used to be just
locked to our tvs like now we can take
games with us and i think that's really
important especially back when we used
to travel a lot i mean now we're not
doing it as much
i don't know i mean i'm looking forward
to traveling actually right now we're
traveling we're not at home we are out
on a special project
shooting something really fun so we
brought everything with us
and you have your surface book up there
yeah that's surface book three
hook up your uh controller and we could
be playing
anything that's compatible with it yeah
wait until 5g
is a thing like there's gonna be like
that low latency it's high speed like
it's gonna feel like we're at home but
we could be anywhere i love it oh i'm
excited the future is gonna be so cool
well hopefully
i think the future's gonna be i think
it's gonna be cool if we're gonna have
good games and good consoles to look
forward to at least
we will go back into playing video games
and live our life there but
i know we were also talking about how
fun it's been kind of
reinventing ourselves on twitch like
just being able to connect with the
community
has been so much fun because we actually
get to talk to you guys directly and
play games with you guys
it's so much fun so thank you guys for
being so amazing and so supportive i
think that's it for for this special
episode i look forward to hearing what
you guys thought of the xbox games
showcase and what you're most looking
forward to because there's so much more
to announce
this was just games that were coming out
that you could play on game pass
like this is there's so much more that
we don't even know a little tease
yes anyways thank you guys so much for
watching or listening um you can leave a
review
on our apple podcast as well as a voice
message
on anchor dot fm slash same brain we
listened to those
we didn't do any today but we did it in
the next episodes you can stay tuned and
you can hear
some of those so that's it yay we'll see
you guys later see you later bye
[Music]
you